tulsi and Hillary Hillary and Tulsi it's
still on and Tulsi is winning people
warned me in 2016
that my endorsement of Bernie Sanders
would be the end of my quote unquote
political career but if they can falsely
portray me as a traitor then they can do
it to anyone you stand up against
Hillary they will destroy you and
discredit your message but here is the
truth they will not intimidate us it's
like a message from the future
she's like a Hawaiian Sarah Connor
you've been trumped wait in aa Hillary
Clinton if you've heard of her Hillary
Clinton have you've heard of her she's
the one that's accusing everybody of
being a Russian agent anybody that is
opposed to her as a Russian agent tulsi
I don't know tell C which is done a
Russian agent
I don't know Jill Stein I know she likes
environment not only she elects Russians
these people are sick there's something
wrong with them but I think that the
tulsi gabbard probably got helped quite
a bit by mr. meanwhile an MSNBC panel
mocked tulsi for not denying that she
was a Russian asset one thing that was
interesting about Tulsi gabbard's
response I mean she went after Hillary
Clinton she was strong she said that she
wasn't going to run as a third party
candidate she never denied being a
Russian accent would be the press you
know in the first line or two it was not
there yeah what a moronic giggle fest
sorry tilt she's not an asset but what a
set of asses speaking of here's joy she
hasn't denied it she hasn't said
anything in her tweets how dare you it's
outrageous of course I'm not just say
that she's just going after Hillary I
just think that she could be a useful
idiot the way Trump is a useful idiots
of the Russia
that they see they see something they
say oh look at useful idiot let's play
this joy calling someone an idiot I'd
say that's the pot calling the kettle
black but pots have a higher IQ but this
few draws quite the contrast if there's
anyone who reminds you of the past one
of murky sleaze
it's a clinton their favorite smear
russian asset they said trump was one
and now they're saying it's a young
clear-eyed female veteran who served her
country while rejecting conventional
ideologies there's lots to disagree with
on tulsi but at least you know she's
real which is why the Dems fear her the
party of identity politics can't figure
her identity out maybe that's why so
many Republicans like her she isn't
manufactured and please the bots at
MSNBC but Hillary is her bitter idiotic
commentary keeps reminding you of why
Trump won think about it she says this
so-called Russian asset would split the
Democratic vote if she went rogue
no she's likely pulled more arse than DS
despite what Hillary claims twelve sees
no Jill Stein she's sane a vet with a
libertarian bent one that's not to the
left of the Dems but to the right of the
Dems so not only is Hillary stupidly
wrong about Tulsi she makes it clear who
the Republican asset really is it's
Hillary every time she opens her mouth
she makes the Dems look sad are we sure
she's not on Trump's payroll day can I
have a theory I haven't named it yet but
I call it smear by external preference
that means you could be in a punk band
right a very popular punk band but among
your fans are skinheads so some of them
could say uh your skinhead band or
you're a skinhead asset so she could
have a ton of fans some of them are
Russian some of them are Canadian she
can't help likewise we can't help who
our fans are so if Canadians like you
are you a Canadian asset you see my
point yes
I'm not a Canadian asset I generally
rebuff Justin Bieber and Jim Carrey at
any at any opportunity but you mentioned
the word bitter and I wrote down
bitterness is Hillary's favorite color
of lipstick that's pretty clear all of
her failings all of her failures she
can't take
ownership of them to her fans and
they're still a few she should have been
able to beat Trump as easy as driving
through a McDonald's drive-thru but she
can't and in that in that Plouffe
podcast that she did of course she has
to go after Fox News but she longs for
the day where there were just three
three television networks and a few
newspapers and she actually had the
audacity to say it was a much more
controllable environment she says so
it's a lot harder for Americans to know
what they're supposed to believe that's
how she views the world that she's out
there to the American people know what
they believe in and they don't believe
in you by yeah you're Dana don't you
agree that if Tulsi ran it would
wouldn't it hurt Trump more than it
would hurt the Dems because you hear it
from Republicans but independence more
about how much they like Tulsi than
anybody and the Dems am I wrong I I
sense that but on the Left one of the
things that they some on the Left have a
problem with toast a gabber because she
would she's not anti-war right she's a
kind of a hawk but she would use drones
yeah things like that and there are a
lot of liberals who don't want that at
all either right the Criterion's I'm not
sure so much for that as well but if
you're a Jill so 1.4 million people
voted for Jill Stein in the election
that's not not out of three hundred and
thirty million people that's not that
many but if you were one of them would
you be motivated to return to the
Democratic fold after this after they
after Hillary going after Tulsi Gabbard
probably not look good necessarily mean
that I don't think that means that
they're gonna she's gonna all of a
sudden turn into Republican voters but
toasty Gabbard also gained fifty
thousand followers up for this you got a
ton of free publicity yeah
and for what like what does it
accomplish for Hillary Clinton I don't
know I I don't know if it's anything
yeah maybe more book sales cuz she needs
the money you know needs a fourth house
Jesse one of my smartest friends Walter
is a hundred percent positive that she's
entering the race one of my other
smarter friends Scott says there's no
way Scott out yes
where would you say do you think this is
all because she's coming back no I don't
think she's gonna enter the race
and there's there's people don't like
her people don't like her on the right
they don't like her in the middle and
now a lot of people on the left don't
like her she's a feminist Greg and she
smeared a female combat veteran that's
just think about that this woman went to
overseas to lay her life down for her
country and Hillary's smearing her as a
Russian she probably actually had sniper
fire over her head whereas Hillary just
lied about it and then Hillary is so
tough on Russia I mean a few years ago
she was giggling with the reset button
laughing it up yucking it up she's so
tough a couple years ago she called
Assad a reformer a reformer and then I
think it was in 2011 Nancy Pelosi Waxman
a bunch of Democrats went over to Syria
John Kerry at dinner hands with Assad
they didn't want to now now they have to
kill him to be tough and if you don't
want to kill him you're a Russian asset
it's so crazy now the Democrats have
never been tough on Russia remember I
mean they were like you know communist
sympathisers 75 years ago they were
against everything Ronald Reagan was
doing to defeat the Soviet Union and you
know Romney got mocked for saying Russia
was a threat now they turn around and
they said oh if you're not against a
Russia you know they did all these kinds
of things pointed missiles at us proxy
wars but they hack a Democrats computer
and all of a sudden we're in World War 3
it's crazy you cannot have a legitimate
disagreement on the left over foreign
policy now without getting smeared as a
Russian agent all right one is she a
Russian agent are you a Russian agent
one if you look just at the heart
politics of it Hillary Clinton has no
political future she's not running
really and I think that what you have
here is that she's free to speak her
mind and she does not want a repeat of
what happened with a third party
candidate in 2016 because remember Jill
Stein got 1% in Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania that exceeded the margin of
Trump's victory over Hillary Clinton
we're talking
big jump in terms of electoral votes but
Tulsa finish let me just say and
remember Jill Stein Jill Stein's a
dinner with Putin and Michael Flynn in
2015 where do you see she gets like two
percent right now in the post but guess
what she's all over Artie she's all over
Sputnik right she gets lots of attention
and I think this is what you were
referring to gets lots of attention from
far-right conspiracy people they love
her the bots lover you can understand
why people are saying hey wait a second
are the Russians trying to exploit tulsi
gabbard she doesn't need to be a Russian
asset she can just be someone who's
exploited to diminish Democratic than
that's not and Democrat goes to my point
which is it's you can't control an
external preference if someone is a fan
of your band you can't say no no but
this is politics and when politics if
you Natalie right-wing people supporting
Tulsi Gabbard they have a reason no
actually right-wing people supporting
Tulsi Gabbard hurts them because they
won't vote for Trump no she's still
being used by the right to finish you
was not to be into your conspiracy I
think you're overplaying the bots you
guys control the whole media I'm going
to get a few Bob oh my god you're waking
for phase a do we call you Mark
Zuckerberg oh my god